[Music]
foreign
book in history no volume ever written
has been more loved and quoted and its
words sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious should always be studied
carefully it is the Bible the word of
God welcome to Bible answers live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
Bible related question give us a call
now at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Doug
Batchelor
Hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
an anechoic chamber is a very carefully
insulated room designed to eliminate all
sound
or field Laboratories in Minnesota has
built what is listed as the quietest
place on earth a chamber so quiet that
the longest anybody has been able to
Bear it is 45 minutes it's
99.99 sound absorbent and it holds a
Guinness World Record for the world's
quietest place
the inside of the small room is lined on
all six sides with a deep fiberglass
wedges a double wall of insulated steel
and one foot thick reinforced concrete
inside the room It's So Silent that
background noise is actually measured in
negative decibels it is so quiet you'll
hear your heart beating your stomach
gurgling I hear that anyway sometimes
and your bones grinding but the room
isn't just for torturing people
companies rent the room to test their
products and to find out just how loud
they really are even NASA has sent
astronauts there to help them experience
the absolute science Silence of space
you know pass her off sometimes when you
live in the city and there's all this
background noise you long to find a
place where you can have a little bit of
peace and quiet even if you get out of
the the busyness of the city and you go
to the country you find a quieter place
but you still hear the wind blowing you
hear the chirping of the of the birds
and so on but a place where there is
absolute silence you can understand why
somebody can only be in there for 45
minutes we're not used to that kind of
Silence yeah they used to call them I
think um isolation Chambers where it
would kind of isolate you and separate
you from all sound for some reason that
sounds attractive to me some people some
people when it's totally quiet it
unnerves them evidently right I'd like
to take the test here and see if I can
make it more than 45 minutes I'll bet
you I could but um you know it makes me
think about a verse in the Bible that
talks about silence in a place where you
wouldn't expect it to be absolutely
silent and that's heaven in Revelation
chapter 8 verse 1 it says he opened the
seventh seal
and there was silence in heaven for
about half an hour now normally in
heaven you figure that the angels are
singing you know the vision that Isaiah
had of God on his throne the angels are
crying out holy holy holy and in the
presence of the Lord you just picture
there's going to be this awesome music
and
to have that you know they they say the
worst thing you can do in radio is have
what they call dead air that's where you
have no sound
and uh people will change channels in
heaven to have dead air
it says about the space of half an hour
what do you think that means well you
know it's interesting you do find these
different time periods in Bible prophecy
and the Bible tells us as a principle of
an interpreting Bible time prophecy one
prophetic day is equal to one literal yo
so uh Scholars have done the math there
are 360 days in a Hebrew year 24 hours
in the day so you divide 360 by 24 you
end up with 15 15 days which would be
al-time but here the verse says they
silence in heaven about the space of a
half an hour so you would you would need
to cut that 15 day and a half so 15 days
prophetically would be about an hour one
hour and then a half an hour would be
well seven days about a week yeah that's
interesting now why would it be quiet in
heaven for a week what do you think it
will be quiet in heaven because
something very important is happening
and we know that when Jesus comes the
second time he's going to bring all of
the angels with him and if there's
anyone else left in heaven I'm sure
their focus is on what's Happening Here
in the Earth at the second coming of
Christ so that half an hour of Silence
in heaven Israeli taking place in the
future when Jesus comes the second time
and it's it's at the end it's I guess
the seventh seal that's right is when
that happens well that makes sense
because it does say there in Prophecy
that when Christ comes it says he's
coming and all the angels with him not
some angels so if all the angels that
sing God's Praise In Heaven are gone
it would be quiet now it is interesting
if there's seven days of Silence in
heaven well that would mean that it
would probably take about seven days for
the journey from Earth back to Heaven I
don't think it takes three and a half
days for Jesus to come of the angels and
then three and a half days to go back
because you know angels can travel at
the speed of thought so I would assume
then that Christ and the angels come
quickly to the Earth and then the
Journey Back To Heaven takes about seven
days it maybe take us on a little tour
that's right
at the scenic route well we're looking
forward to what the Bible calls the
Blessed hope when Jesus comes again and
there's several references to the second
coming in the Prophecies of Daniel in
Revelation we have a study guide a free
guide if someone wants to study and
learn something about not only The
Nearness of Jesus return according to
the prophecies but something about how
he's going to return because we know
Satan's going to try to trick people and
they'll be false christs and he'll maybe
even try to fabricate the second coming
somehow we want to know something about
that and we have a free offer we do it's
one of the amazing facts study guides
and it's called the ultimate deliverance
and really it's all about the second
coming of Christ all the scriptures are
there just a great study if you're
wondering about what the next big thing
is that's going to happen on Earth well
it's the greatest thing of all the
second coming of Christ we'll be happy
to send it to anyone who calls and asks
the number is
800-835-6747 and you can ask for the
study guide just ask for it by name it's
called the ultimate Deliverance it's the
study guide on the second coming of
Christ you can also ask for free offer
one zero five and we'll be happy to send
that to anyone here in North America
we'll send it to you through the mail if
you're listening outside of North
American pasadag we have folks listening
from other countries at different time
zones if you'd like to read that study
guide just go to the Amazing Facts
website
amazingfacts.org.com and you'll be able
to read that study guide right there at
the website absolutely all right well be
before we go to the phone lines we
always like to begin our program with
prayer so let's just do that right now
dear father once again we are grateful
for this time where we can just open up
your word and study and study the Word
of Life the word of Truth and Lord the
Bible is your book so we need the holy
spirit to guide us so we ask for your
blessing be with us here in the studio
be with those who are listening wherever
they might be in Jesus name amen amen
and of course pastor we want to welcome
all of those who are listening we have
folks listening on satellite radio and
then also land-based radio stations
across the country we have people
listening on the internet on the Doug
Batchelor Facebook page the amazing
facts Facebook page also on YouTube on
AF TV and I think this will be
rebroadcast on some other networks hope
channel 3 again absolutely so we want to
welcome all of those who are tuning in
this is a live interactive Bible study
so if you have a Bible related question
the number to call here is
800-463-7297 that's
800-463-7297 with your Bible question
our first caller this evening is Anthony
and he's listening in New York Anthony
welcome to the program
hi good evening again pastors
good evening
um
yes that amazing fact was actually
perfect for the question I have today
um and I'll as I always say I'll try to
be concise
um but my question
is I guess based on uh Ecclesiastes
chapter 3 verse 1 where
um it says for everything there is a
season and a time for every purpose
under heaven now I know uh well my
question has to do with emotions in in
church worship and what their role is
and you know there's different emotions
that we feel whether it's excitement and
joy gladness but also
um reflectiveness Peace salinity so I'm
just wondering my in general my question
is what is the role of the the range of
emotions when it comes to Worship in
light of the fact that you know for
example as we just talked about the
quietness in heaven was going to be
quiet I would think that that you know
we can presume that it's loud in heaven
or you know where wherein um Isaiah
chapter 6 where it says that Angels go
back and forth shouting holy holy holy
and and when someone gives their life to
Christ all the Angels rejoice and and
and and and so you know with singing and
joy and then even with David I know it
wasn't in the context of church a church
per se but where he you know he danced
you know a dancer of Joy more so you
know he was you know joyous with
excitement and I know we tend to you
know try to be more reserved in church
and more reflective and solemn church
but is there a role for the emotion of
excitement and I'm trying to figure out
what's the biblical balance for the two
yeah that is a great question
um you know when you read the Bible
you'll find examples well first of all
let me let me just set up a big context
for this
um when we're in the presence of God the
Bible teaches consistently that there
should be reverence now you find verses
in the Bible that says the Lord is in
his holy Temple at all the Earth keeps
silent speaking of Silence
uh so there's a time for for silence and
reverence then you find when they
gathered for the reading of the word in
the book of Ezra the people were
convicted and they wept and then Ezra
told the people do not wait we today is
a day for rejoicing
and there are times when Solomon
dedicate the uh the temple and the fire
god came down the people fell on their
faces there was fear and there was all
so you can see based on the the context
of what's happening and the preacher
might be preaching a sermon where some
are greatly comforted and there's
rejoicing others might be convicted and
there's like the Republican that smote
upon his breast and said Lord be
merciful to me a sinner
so all things should be done in the
context of reverence we've all seen
church services probably on TV where it
looks like a hootenanny and there's just
it's chaos Paul says let all things be
done decently in order but that doesn't
mean there shouldn't be great joy I
think when people sing look at all the
Psalms that talk about you know Joy To
The Lord and rejoicing
now if my rejoicing totally distracts
the other person I went to a church
where there was this one individual that
every time I made a point
there was a a loud Hallelujah that would
almost make the people around them jump
and I appreciated the encouragement but
it was distracting everybody else
because it was so loud
that um I had to ask him I said look can
you can you dial the volume down a
little bit
so you don't want you're rejoicing or
you're weeping or whatever it is to be a
spectacle that's going to distract other
people from hearing the word so there's
that balance I don't know what do you
think Pastor Ross yeah absolutely you
know when one enters into the presence
of God into a house of worship the
church and you're going to worship I
think it's appropriate to come in with
reverence with quietness understanding
that you're in the presence of God and
you're preparing your heart for worship
but as you mentioned throughout the
worship service there are appropriate
times for uh singing and rejoicing and
praising God but there are also other
times for quiet reflection contemplation
listening to the word so I think that
job even says it's time to wail and he's
talking about repentance though right so
sometimes when people should repent and
and he said they should wail and weep
and those are you know hopefully not the
weekly service right but yeah so great
question Anthony I don't know if that
helped your answer at all but um
yeah like it says here you you gave us a
scripture from Solomon to everything
there's a season and a time for every
purpose under heaven so there are times
for fasting and prayer and maybe weeping
there certainly are times for rejoicing
as the Angels rejoice and praising God
the gospel is called good news it's uh
the context I think okay very good
always done with reverence we've got
coal listening in North Dakota call
Welcome to the program
thank you thank you
um the question I have
is from Isaiah 45 verse 7.
um it's I'll read the text real quick
okay
um I form the light and create Darkness
I make peace and create evil I the Lord
do all these things I know other
translations use words like Calamity or
disaster but
I had a discussion of some people about
this and they made a point about God
does create evil for his glory but I'm
my question is does God actually create
evil
if he's perfect yeah no that this is
actually I think uh at least in the King
James version it's sort of an
unfortunate translation we get that
question a lot where God says I create
evil
um
you look at the Book of Job and look at
the the calamities That Came Upon job
and here the devil came to God and said
you know job is the only reason he
serves you is because you've hedged him
in with angels you protect him and you
bless him and if you take away your
protection he'll curse you to your face
and God says okay I'm going to withdraw
my protection but there's limits on what
you can do so God is Sovereign in the
sense that he had to loosen the devil's
leash
but it was the devil that did it so God
created a beautiful angel who was given
a free will who chose to do evil now the
Bible says every good and per this is
the Book of James every good and perfect
gift comes from God Jesus said God is
good and so you cannot be simultaneously
light in darkness good and evil well we
know the consequence of evil is sorrow
suffering and death you know it's
Rebellion you know God wouldn't create
something that would lead to Rebellion
suffering and death contrary to his
nature God is a god of love so if you're
looking the devil's really the author of
of evil exactly so this verse we kind of
straight a little bit from it but the
verse that you're talking about in
Isaiah chapter 45 verse 7 where he said
uh I make peace and create evil as you
mentioned my like the new King James
says Cree Calamity and the word there
would really be I allow calamity
so sometimes God allows trials to come
and when the flood came on the world
well
God said I'm going to send a flood it's
the language that he uses it was to
punish the evil
and so Isaiah is saying I'm the one who
ultimately has Sovereign final power
hope that helps good question
Mexico that we have is soulless
listening in Arkansas Solas welcome to
the program
hello Pastor hi thank you for having me
my question is is on Luke chapter 16
verse 9 and it's after the parable of
the unjust Steward and it's when Jesus
says and I say to you make friends for
yourselves by means of under unrighteous
wealth that when you fail they may
receive you into the Everlasting home so
I'm kind of confused on that could you
explain that
yeah this is a parable that has left a
lot of people wondering Jesus talks
about this Steward that is very
Unfaithful and realizing he's going to
be fired he enters into agreements with
the debtors of his master
so that they basically become
accomplices with him and Jesus is he's
um complimenting and you can read this
in verse 8 I believe it says so the
master commended the unjust Steward why
would you commence somebody unjust he's
not commending him for being unjust he's
saying what you've done is wise you are
looking ahead and you are making plans
to protect your future and you notice in
the end of this Parable he says that the
children of this age are often wiser
than the children of light
meaning that the people in the world you
know they'll they'll do things to plan
to secure their future
but a lot of people say they're
Believers aren't really planning for
their Everlasting future
so when he says I say make for yourself
friends of unrighteous Mammon that when
you fail they may receive you into an
everlasting home I Think Jesus is saying
that we ought to invest using the
world's resources invest in saving
people we're going to see them through
eternity in heaven
do you have any thoughts on that yeah I
think you're right Pastor Doug you know
sometimes in The Parables of Jesus Jesus
used this contrast to illustrate the
important truth so if the wicked are
preparing for their Eternal future
meaning destruction because they focus
on the things of this Earth shouldn't we
as Believers also be preparing for what
we believe to be a future in Paradise
with Christ and with the saved the
redeemed in heaven we need to be
preparing for that we need to be getting
ready for that and as you said utilizing
our resources and our influence to help
get other people into the kingdom as
well yep
so hope that helps a little Solas and we
sure appreciate your call
next question yeah next holiday that we
have is uh Joan listening in Arkansas
Joan welcome to the program
I think you mean Joan from Anchorage
Alaska oh there it is okay sorry Alaska
welcome
well good evening good evening pastors
um I was wondering if you could help me
to understand who the eight kings are
that are mentioned in Revelation 17
verse 10 and 11. I can read that for you
I tell you what why don't you let us
read it because you were getting
terrible feedback you may have your
radio on in the background
really yeah so if uh I don't know how is
it now there we go that's better so you
go ahead you can read it okay it says
there are
here this is chapter verse nine here is
the mind which has wisdom the seven
heads are seven mountains on which the
woman sits there are also seven Kings
five have fallen one is and the other
has not yet come and when he comes he
must continue a short time and the Beast
that was and is not is himself also the
eight and is of the seventh and he is
going and is going into Perdition so I
was just wondering if you could let me
know who these eight kings are all right
good we'll do our best now I'll just go
I'll tell you right at the outset that
even within my church there are probably
four major interpretations of this you
know we're not cookie cutters where
everybody has every answer for
everything and so there are different
views on this prophecy I'll tell you
what I teach and what you're going to
find typically in The Amazing Facts
lessons it says that this woman is
sitting on seven Mountain well most
scholars believe that the the woman of
Revelation 17 is talking about the
papacy a woman is a church here's a
woman who's been unfaithful because the
papacy they started to turn to idolatry
and they you know adopted a number of
pagan doctrines they were seen as the
Harlot or the Unfaithful woman sitting
among Seven Hills Rome is the city of
Seven Hills now this is what Luther and
Calvin and Spurgeon and Wesley the so
many Protestants taught and unitedly
believe this but it says that those
seven hills are also seven Kings or
kingdoms on which he sits it says five
are Fallen now some take the perspective
that when John wrote this
a Rome Pagan Rome was in power so the
five before would be you've got the five
powers that occupy in God's people which
were Egypt Assyria
uh Babylon medo-persia and Greece five
were Fallen after Greece fell it says
one is that would be Pagan Rome Rome
ruled by Caesars then the one who is the
um the spiritual problem would be the
seventh which is the papacy
but it receives a deadly wound and
recovers and comes back into Power
that's why it says he's also the eighth
how can the seventh also be the eight
unless it takes a break and comes back
and so and it talks about this Beast
receiving a deadly one but the wound is
healed in Revelation 13. so hopefully
you could take that all and that's
that's the way that a number of Scholars
understand it but not all
so uh and I think you'd find that in our
lessons I don't remember what lesson it
is we're talking oh that's the woman
yeah the uh The Other Woman it's a
lesson called The Other Woman that you
can get and if you'd like to receive the
lesson just call and ask the number to
call for that is
800-835-6747 and you can ask for the
study guide It's called The Other Woman
and we'll be happy to send it out to
anyone who calls and asks thank you Joan
from Arkansas Alaska yeah
next color that we have is uh Edna from
Michigan Edna welcome to the program
hi guys thank you for taking my phone
call yeah my question tonight comes out
of Revelation and it's about the seven
last plagues
I know the controversy is about God's
seventh day Sabbath and man we're
shipping on the last on the first day
and about the time of trouble the close
of probation but I do not understand
what is the purpose of the seven last
plagues okay good
keep in mind the seven last plagues are
something of a parallel to what happened
in Exodus in Exodus God was getting
ready to take his people from slavery to
the promised land Jesus is getting ready
to take his people from the slavery of
the devil in this world to the promised
land of Heaven
and there's these 10 plagues that fell
on Egypt now the last seven of the ten
plagues God protects even the Israelites
from those it doesn't affect the land of
Goshen so you've got the seven plagues
of Egypt do not affect the Israelites
the first three did
um
and you're saying well if if a
probation's close and why is God
allowing this well it's for one thing
it's showing they did not repent
when the plagues came on the Egyptians
even the Pharaoh says he repented and
the Egyptians said let them go there
were some repentance but the wicked of
the world they have no redeemable
qualities left they've hardened their
hearts there's nothing that God can do
and he's demonstrating to their friends
family and unfallen worlds that the
world even under these trials does not
soften their hearts and turn to God but
they Harden their hearts and they
blaspheme and they Curse God so it's
something of a demonstration you know
under the fifth plague that you read
about in Revelation chapter 16 verse 11.
well let me start in verse 10 it says
then the fifth angel poured out his ball
on the throne of the Beast and the
kingdom became full of darkness and they
nod their tanks because of the pain and
then the next verse says they blasphemed
the god of Heaven because of the pains
and because of the souls and they did
not repent of their deeds so it's
evident here that they recognize that
these are judgments coming from God but
their heart is so hardened that the
rebel even unto these judgments and they
blaspheme the name of God that's right
so the plagues reveal the true condition
of the heart but at the same time you
find another group in Revelation that
when the plagues have been full or
falling upon the Earth they're trusting
in God they're rejoicing because they
know the end is coming their faith is
being tested and tried but they are are
shown to be genuine they true and those
are the ones that have the Seal of God
so the plagues reveal the two groups
right at the end of time and they are
something of a judgment because when the
blood the ocean and the Springs become
blood the angel says they've shed the
blood of the Saints you're giving them
blood to drink right so it's they're
kind of it's something of a judgment as
well as a demonstration things that's a
good question Edna we appreciate it
all right maybe one more question before
we take our break we have Dez listening
in Florida Des welcome to the program
hello welcome thank you hi
hi
it's about
um
the last days
because we I noticed that something we
talked about what the leaves the city
and
um moving to the country is somewhere
and uh
I don't understand I mean I don't know
it's hard to say no I I think I
understand
yeah no it's a good question in the last
days uh when Jesus says in Matthew 24
when you see the abomination of
desolation stand in the Holy place let
those that be in Judea flee into the
mountains I think in uh Luke it says
when you see Jerusalem Encompass with
armies let those at be in Judea flee
into the mountains so for ancient Israel
when the abomination of desolation came
the Roman army surrounded them that was
a signal to flee there was a brief break
in that Siege and they fled
um in the last days God's people are
going to be hedged in again by laws
religious laws that compel worship first
you can't buy or sell and ultimately
there'll be a death decree and when we
see that those laws are coming
that's going to be a time for we
probably want to get out of the cities
and especially and that doesn't mean
everybody can afford to you know sell
their home and go buy a country estate
um but we should be moving towards more
remote places I think the Lord is
warning us just very practically we saw
in recent years there's been some social
unrest and cities were on fire and and
there were there are places in uh you
know Portland Oregon and stuff you
couldn't even drive downtown we had some
friends that lived there and they said
it was just terrible and and a number of
Minneapolis and and Florida and
Washington DC you know police marching
up the street you didn't see that kind
of rioting going on in Podunk you know
these little farm towns they didn't they
didn't have that same kind of threat so
you're a little safer in more remote
communities during that time and so I
think that's the warning then you got
that verse there in Isaiah woe unto them
to join house the house and lay feel to
field Hill there's no place that a man
can be alone in the Earth it's nice to
have a place more alone we're going to
take a break come back with more Bible
questions after these messages
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
every year 40 000 souls in North America
end their own lives
suicide is a terrible tragedy and while
it's difficult to talk about we need to
face it together as Christians
that's why in my new book choosing life
I share the biblical perspective about
suicide answering some difficult
questions about faith and salvation
along the way and offering practical
tips that should help and encourage
others Jesus wants us to choose an
abundant life in him
[Music]
foreign
what would you do
what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past Alexander the Great becomes
king when he's only 18 but he's a
military prodigy
150 years in advance Cyrus had been
named
Rome was violent they were ruthless they
were determined this intriguing
documentary hosted by Pastor Doug
Batchelor explores the most striking
Bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history Kingdoms in time
are you ready
written by the hand of God and spoken
with his voice
some words will
foreign
er's 12-part sermon series on the Ten
Commandments by calling
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
welcome back listening friends and if
you've joined us along the way this is
Bible answers live and we do our best to
answer Bible questions from around the
world and actually we've got some lines
open I have a couple people in line but
if you'd like to call in with your Bible
question you can call 800 God says
that's
800-463-7297 or you can be watching also
on the internet we're streaming on
Facebook and as well as some television
stations my name is Doug Batchelor my
name is John Ross and our next caller
that we have is Paul listening from
Washington State Paul you're on the air
yes I am
my question is
what does the Bible say about
having a large sum of money in the bank
or in Investments near the last days
a good question
um
I'm looking up a verse right now yeah
there's there's a parable that Jesus
tells in Luke chapter 12 where he said
he spoke apparently this is verse 16
Luke 12 16. he spoke a parable to them
saying the ground of a certain rich man
yielded plentifully and he thought
within himself saying what shall I do
since I have no room to store my crops
so he said I'll do this I'll pull down
my Barns and I'll build bigger Barns and
they're all store all my crops and my
goods and I'll say soul you have many
Goods laid up for many years take your
ease eat drink and be merry
but God said to him fool this night your
soul will be required of you then whose
will those things be which you have
provided
and Jesus says so is he who lays up
treasure for himself and is not rich
towards God he certainly don't want to
be hoarding and stockpiling resources
you know and this is a great question
Paul because
well does that mean everybody is to give
away everything they have right now
uh doesn't mean we should save nothing
and I really like the way John Wesley
dealt with this issue he said a
Christian should earn all they can
they should save all they can and they
should give all they can
so I think there's a balance we don't
know exactly when the Lord's going to
come so you know it's probably a good
idea to have some savings for yourself
and your family and you know if you're
working hard and you're earning you
should also be able to give
and give generously
so that I think is the principle if the
you know even if you divided your
resources the way I just stated it and
you said all right well I'm gonna you
know need one-third for living one-third
for saving and one-third for giving
I mean that'd be imagine how radical
that would be for the church to say a
third of what I have I'm going to give
to God's work
man the gospel would go into all the
world pretty quick
and just even the spirit that it would
take to do that you know Jesus said
something else in Luke chapter 12 verse
33 Jesus said where your treasure is
that's where your heart is also so if
you're utilizing our resources to build
up the Kingdom of Heaven that's going to
be our passion that's where our heart is
but if our goal is just to treasure up
treasure here on this Earth well our
heart's in the wrong place yep
all right thanks Nicole you know we do
have a study guide It's called in God we
trust that it's talking about what the
Bible says about finance and we'll be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
and asks the number is
800-835-6747 and you can ask for the
study guide It's called In God We Trust
and we'll be happy to send it to anyone
in North America amen we've got uh Aaron
listening in New York Aaron welcome to
the program
good evening pastors and thank you for
taking my call
Jeremiah chapter 17 verse 21 says thus
set the Lord take heed to yourselves and
bear no burden on a Sabbath day nor
bring it into the Gates of Jerusalem
well the Jewish leaders during the time
when Jesus walked on Earth believed that
one of the people
Jesus healed broke this law by carrying
his bed
but Jesus discreet about that
my question is what is the meaning of
the word burden in Jeremiah chapter 17
verse 21.
yeah well first of all when Jesus healed
a man he said take up your bed and go to
your house
uh and I think he did that on a couple
occasions once with the well I don't
know that it was a Sabbath day the the
paralytic doesn't say it was a Sabbath
the um blind man I think he took up his
stuff and went home and the man pool of
Bethesda that was the seventh yeah yeah
so
um that's a whole different kind of
Burden than Jeremiah is talking about
people that were carrying burdens of
goods to sell they were doing buying and
selling and business and uh you know
carrying if if Jesus heals and you got
to take your sleeping bag home
uh that's not Sabbath breaking
so you know Jesus is saying it's better
to do good on the sabbathy some people
look at the disputes that Jesus had
regarding the Sabbath matter of fact
probably one of the most disputed of the
Ten Commandments that Jesus had with the
scribes and the Pharisees was regarding
the Sabbath he never said you should not
keep it the arguments were always about
how to keep it and basically he said you
know you've put undue burdens on people
asking them to uh you know
carry legalistic laws that you won't
lift with one of your fingers
he healed a woman who was bent over on
the Sabbath day and he said This Woman's
been bound by the devil for 18 years and
you guys will untie your ox and your
donkey and water them on the Sabbath
there you'll milk your goat or your cow
why wouldn't you want to relieve the
burden of this lady on the Sabbath day
and and heal her so I don't know if
that's answering your question but Aaron
hopefully that helps a little bit I
think the context of the whole concern
here that Jeremiah has is that there
were those who were bringing in their
goods into Jerusalem on the Sabbath to
sell baked goods and finally you know
the gates were eventually have to be
closed a little later when you read
about Israel Nehemiah so I think the
point here is just conducting regular
business of course in those days they
would go into the field they'd have to
get up the grain they'd have to carry it
into the city that's not an appropriate
work to do on the Sabbath right
all right thank you for your call we've
got Aaron now also Aaron listening from
California Aaron welcome to the program
a good evening thank you so much for
taking my call yes
uh pastors I had a question uh recently
my wife uh came across a video online
that uh had a person who is a personal
video they made and in the video they
they sort of Twisted I believe what they
did was twist uh the scripture because
they wanted to basically say that
because God created man and God created
man male and female and he created them
in His image that somehow that means
that God is non-binary and uh so I you
know I I from my understanding you know
the male and female how God created uh
man was for the purpose of reproduction
and God does not need male or female to
reproduce so I don't believe that he is
so I believe that what it's what it
talks about when it says we are created
in His image is that we not that we look
like God or that God looks like us but
that we have the characteristics of God
such as the capacity for creativity and
I just was curious what your thoughts
are as far as perhaps maybe more
specifically what the Bible might say in
reference to how man is created in God's
image
well
um I do think the Bible teaches us of
course God is a spirit that doesn't mean
God has no form
uh the person of the godhead that might
be difficult for us to comprehend as far
as the form would be God the spirit who
sometimes is appearing as everything
from fire and water to a dove
and wind but um
when the Bible talks about the visions
that the apostles saw
uh Daniel and John in Ezekiel and Isaiah
it talks about God having hands head
feet legs it says on Jesus thigh and it
portrays him with I don't want to say it
portrays him
uh it's like telling a child your
parents look like you well no they look
like their parents so you know Jesus is
portrayed having these features that we
have we have them because he has them
so I think God must have some form
because the other thing is Jesus Took
humanity and he's now going to bear that
through eternity
uh you know he permanently identified
himself with humanity and even in his
resurrection form so
um but to say that God is non-binary
someone is trying to politicize our uh
you know get get the nature of God
caught up in some of the cultural issues
today and that's a that's a sensational
stretch
um God has consistently referred to as
our father in The Bible and but I don't
believe that he has gender in the sense
that we do so it's silly to try and
classify him as male female or even
binary anyway so hopefully that helps a
little Aaron and appreciate your
question
next problem that we have is uh Armando
in North Carolina Armando welcome to the
program
uh Pastor John Pastor Sean Ross and
Pastor Doug Batchelor how are you guys
we're thankful to be here
thank you guys for having me oh
uh my question is in regard is regarding
Judges 13 when the angel of the Lord
comes to speak to the wife of Manoa and
I think in uh verses four and five the
angel of the Lord starts to I guess
specify
um that the I guess the vowel will be
taken on by the mother but then
essentially Samson will have the
nazerite valve I just wanted to see if
that's
um if if that's the case with Samsung
taking on the Nazareth above I have a
couple of footnotes and a couple Bibles
that indicate that the Nazarite valve is
in numbers six yes and um and then and
then I just had a follow-up question if
that was the case how was Samsung able
to
um Carry On the valve when uh whenever
he would sin or you know kill a body
when he was against the Army and you
know the the the the
uh and it's specific in numbers about
coming with a dead body in well let's
let's just be honest
um Samson did a pretty terrible job of
keeping the vow of an eserate his
parents did their best during the
gestation of the baby and in his raising
to convince him that he was special got
a special plan for him he had taken the
Nazarite vow but he seems to be
rebelling against that during his life
he wasn't supposed to drink wine but it
seems like he did he wasn't supposed to
touch a dead body but we know that he
did I mean he killed a lion and ate
honey out of it and he picked up the
Jawbone of a donkey and slew a thousand
men and then he went and stayed with a
harlot in Gaza which is obviously
breaking the Nazarite vow and finally
his hair not being cut and he betrays
that secret and God says enough's enough
you know and he was very patient with
them but um yeah Samson uh he he didn't
do a very good job in following that vow
his parents had sort of consecrated him
now conversely you have Hannah you got
manoa's wife who tries their best to
raise Samson to follow the vow and he
Rebels against it you have Hannah who
makes the Nazarite vow for Samuel Samuel
keeps it
and he is consecrated through his life
to the Lord that way
so you're right those Nazarite vowels
and numbers there are pretty definitive
all right thanks for your call we've got
Maggie listening in Washington Maggie
welcome to the program
hedge about you for your protection
um yeah my question is are the 24 Elders
in the Book of Revelation are are they
the saints that were that Matthew 27 52
mentions after Jesus resurrection
well that's another one of those verses
and I'll also have Pastor Ross weigh in
on this the question is
when it says there's these 24 Elders how
they get to heaven are they some of the
Saints resurrected there in the end of
Matthew
uh or are they the leaders of unfallen
Worlds now I'm more inclined to go with
a ladder you can read that that says
there was a day when the sons of gods
came together before the Lord in heaven
and you wonder who are these sons of God
well when Luke goes through the
genealogy of humanity it talks about
Enos who is the son of Seth who is the
son of Adam who is the son of God
So Adam is called the Son of God because
he is created he isn't born
and these are the leaders We Believe of
unfallen Worlds and in the same way that
God has got 24 leaders in the Old
Testament in Chronicles you read about
24 leaders both militarily and in the
sanctuary as 12 for the day and 12 for
the night or 12 for a half of the Year
God divided them differently and Jesus
has 12 Apostles 12 of course is a 2
times 12 is 24. these are like leaders
of God's unfallen universe is one Theory
I've heard and some believe they're the
resurrected Saints I don't know what are
your thoughts yeah that's a good
question uh you know there is a verse
actually in the Old Testament that talks
about the elders Isaiah 24 23 it says
the Lord shall reign before his eldest
gloriously now that's the Old Testament
of course you have those who are
resurrected the time of Christ's
Resurrection but then you also have in
the Book of Job it talks about the sons
of God or you know these representatives
of these honest thing together that's
right and the devil came representing
Earth
so this was not a meeting that took
place on the earth it was somewhere else
and you have these Representatives so
you know if you look at the the
chronology that's given in in Revelation
chapter four you have a description of
the Heavenly Throne Room God the father
is seated upon the throne and talks
about the fall living creatures and it
mentions they're the 24 elders but it's
not until you get to chapter five that
you see Jesus that he appears so it's as
if Revelation 4 describes Heaven before
Christ comes and if while we know those
who are resurrected at the time of
Christ's Resurrection they were taken to
heaven with Jesus it would seem that the
24-hours already in heaven before Jesus
and those who are resurrected actually
get to heaven so that gives the idea
that 24 Elders would be something more
than just those who are resurrected it's
the other group would be the
representatives of the unfollen Worlds
so I appreciate that hope that helps a
little Maggie and we do have a new
revelation magazine that you can read
it's a revelation or sorry amazing facts
has a magazine on Daniel in Revelation
you can find that at the AF bookstore
that's amazing facts bookstore you'll
see that there next problem we have is
Angela and she is listening in Illinois
she's on the road Angela welcome to the
program
hi I have a question and I think it may
be a misfactory but I'm not sure okay
another
um
sisters talk about you know when the
Bible is preached throughout the world
in Jesus Will Come
but I believe it's Amos chapter 4 where
it says that we should not be wanting to
hasten the day of the Lord because it
will be a day of great
uh
yeah yeah why do you preach the day of
the Lord it'll be a day of distress
and a day of punishment right yeah and
then you put your hand on the wall to
steady yourself and you'll be bitten by
a snake and things like that yes
and a serpent will bite you yeah
I'm looking it up right now
um
yeah that's uh here it is it's Amos 519.
it says um it will be well I can
actually back up it'll be here it says
woe to those who desire the day of the
Lord this is Amos 5 18. woe to you who
desire the day of the Lord for what good
is the day of the Lord to you he's
talking about the wicked why would you
want the day of the Lord It's a day of
darkness and no light it will be as
though a man fled from a lion and a bear
met him that's bad luck or though he
went into the house running for his life
leans on the wall and a serpent bit him
in other words he's saying you can run
but you can't hide no matter where you
go Calamity is going to follow you
because it's a judgment the day of the
Lord is a day of judgment for those who
have neglected the opportunity to have
their sins forgiven and to know the Lord
and be surrendered to the Lord the
second coming is a nightmare for them
it's judgment probation's closed
absolutely you look in Revelation
chapter six right up at the second
coming of Christ The Wicked turned to
the rocks of the mountains and they say
full in us and hide us from the face of
him who sits upon the throne from the
Wrath of the Lamb so it's not a day of
rejoicing for the wicked it is a death
rejoicing for the save for the righteous
but not for the wicked they will say
this is the Lord we have waited for him
and he will save us and the Wicked Will
cast their Idols of gold and silver to
the rats and the bats and the moles and
so you've got this contrast of your
butterflies and your cockroaches when
the Lord comes some go to the light and
some run from the light yeah
thank you appreciate that we've got uh
Jeremiah listening in Texas Jeremiah
welcome to the program
uh thank you for having me pastor
yeah and you were glad to have you your
question
and my question is uh it's about fasting
because um I see in the Bible it seems
fasting has
like for God it's it it seems to elicit
extra attention from God when we when we
add fasting to prayer
and I was I came across this verse in
first Samuel 15 uh 22 where Samuel says
has the Lord has great Delight in burnt
offerings and sacrifices as in obeying
the voice of the Lord behold to obey is
better than sacrifice and to heed than
the fat of rams so what I was wondering
is
if there is some area of sin in your
life
can that interfere with the plight you
are fasting for
well
I I think that when you decide to fast
and pray and reach out to the god that
should involve a a willingness for total
surrender and if you've got some area in
your life that you know is in Rebellion
that ought to be part of your fasting
and your praying so if you're saying oh
Lord I've got this um this sickness and
I want to be healed but you know you're
living in sin well why do you want to be
healed so you get sick and die forever
why don't you say Lord I want to be
healed of sin and then I've got eternal
life and then the physical healing is a
small matter
so you always want to have your
priorities so the worst thing that could
happen to anyone is to be living in sin
still be a captive to the devil because
that's the first thing you ought to be
fascinating and praying for and even
when we do an anointing for somebody
it talks about and if they've committed
sins they'll be forgiven it's understood
when you're praying for healing that
there's some time spent in personal
repentance and getting yourself right
with God if you're going to fast and
pray and you know you've got the parable
of the tax collector and the Pharisee
went to the temple to pray and the
Pharisees said well I fast twice a week
you know and I give my tithe and I do
all to these good deeds and in reality
his fasting didn't mean anything because
he was filled with pride whereas you
know the tax collector he he wept beat
upon his breasts and said Lord be
merciful unto me a sinner and Jesus says
he's the one that went home Justified so
fasting is a lot to do with Attitude
it's not just abstaining from food but
it's abstaining for food for the right
reason right seeking God wanting to gain
Victory yep so hopefully that helps a
little Jeremy we appreciate your call
next what we have is uh Richard in New
York Richard welcome to the program
good evening pastors thank you for
having me on tonight
well thank you
and your question yes
yes ma my question is that I would like
to know does God have a true church on
this Earth
and should we ask Christians and concern
with denominations okay great question
uh I will answer your question with a
question in that uh in the Old Testament
did God have a nation a particular
nation that he called
and to make them the Guardians of his
Oracles of Truth
and that's a rhetorical question because
the answer is yes he clearly called
Ibrahim and his descendants now does
that mean they were better than other
nations does that mean every Jew is
automatically saved no Jews were like
other people there were good ones and
there were bad ones and some were
faithful some were not the early church
you've got some of the Jewish people
that condemn Jesus and the early
churches formed of Jewish people like
the apostles
so does God have a movement now when you
get into the last days is there a
Remnant movement that he has that he has
made a a guardian of the Oracles of
truth I believe the answer is yes
you know obviously if there are hundreds
of different denominations that call
themselves Christians and I believe
there are saved people in many different
churches in the days of Israel God still
had faithful people that weren't even
Israelites the Bible says that you know
God spoke through
Moses father-in-law Jethro he was not in
Israelite he spoke through Naaman a
Naaman was saved and Elijah was sent to
the Canaanite woman and you know God had
his people
um so uh but he he still had a nation a
group that he used and then he organized
them in a special way in the Old
Testament God has an organized work in
the New Testament
um with all these different
denominations we know that some are
going to be closer to the Bible than
others some I think we would agree are
pretty far from the Bible that means
some are going to be closer to the Bible
you want to find the one that is the
closest to the Bible
you know we have a study guide called
the bride of Christ and in the New
Testament the Church the true church is
described as the pride of Christ so what
does the Bible say how what are we to
look for if we're looking for a church
we'll be happy to send the study guide
to anyone who calls and asks just ask
for the study guide is called the bride
of Christ and we'll be happy to send it
to anyone in North America the number is
800-835-6747 that is our resource phone
line just call and ask we'll send you
the study guide the bride of Christ next
holiday we have is uh let's see we've
got JC listening in California Jesse
welcome to the program
thank you very much good evening yeah
the question is regarding the staff of
Moses it's first mentioned in the book
of Exodus chapter 4 verse 2 but not much
information after that
so where would uh please tell me you
might need more information you might
have yeah yeah the Shepherds and Moses
was a shepherd and the nation of Israel
were a nation of shepherds even when
Joseph went
um you know Jacob said we know we're a
nation of shepherds which was largely an
Abomination to the Egyptian Shepherds
all had a rod the Patriarchs of every
family sort of had a rod and they might
be engraved there was some way of
distinguishing them from others because
there was one time when there was a
challenge against Moses and Aaron God
said tell the Elders of Israel to take
their rods they all had a distinctive
rod and an Insignia on it and they were
carved put him before the Lord and God
is going to show you who among the
elders he accepts and it was Aaron's Rod
it starts out here in Exodus 4 talking
about Moses Rod but you go later on it
often calls it Aaron's Rod because Aaron
was the older brother and it seemed like
that that terminology shifted once Aaron
got into Egypt but so Rod represented
the the authority of the family
and rulership so we also find that Jesus
is said to have a rod and Revelation
talks about Christ coming with a rod of
iron meaning he's going to execute
judgment upon the Wicked at the second
coming of Christ so rods or the rod has
symbolic significance in the Bible as
well yeah it says they're they're
shattered as a Potter's vessel when he
comes with the rod and so yeah it's a
symbol of that so hopefully that helps a
little bit and um we appreciate that I'm
looking at the clock I tell you what
listening friends we we do something
unusual here because this radio program
is on hundreds of stations that are both
land-based and some are satellite-based
their time schedules a little different
so we sort of sign off in stages in just
a moment we're going to sign off and say
farewell to those who are listening on
national satellite but we stay on and we
take some rapid fire Bible questions
that come in via the Internet now
someone wants to send us an internet
question Pastor Ross what's the address
for that all you have to do is just
email handled the question to Bal
questions at amazingfacts.org that's Bal
Bible answers live questions at
amazingfacts.org and then we gather
these questions together and we try to
answer as many questions as we could in
about two and a half minutes so we sign
up with our satellite radio and then
we'll encourage land-based stations and
those watching on the internet stay with
us as we're going to address as many of
these questions as we can yeah and thank
you very much those who are listening on
satellite radio
keep in tune and God willing we'll study
with you next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
Hello friends welcome back to Bible
answers live and as we mentioned before
the break this is the time where we take
your Bible questions that you've emailed
to us here at amazing facts so Pastor we
have a number of great questions this
evening so I'm going to get right to it
the first question is why is God going
to restore the earth into a paradise if
everyone is going to heaven when Jesus
comes yeah well we don't go up forever
he first takes us up and we live and
reign with Christ a thousand years in
heaven which is the up Dwelling Place of
God where he is now so first we go to
him he says in my father's house are
many mansions I go to prepare a place
for you if I go I will receive you unto
myself that where I am that place in
heaven we will be but you read in
Revelation 21 at the end of that 1000
Years the New Jerusalem descends from
God out of Heaven comes down to earth
God creates a new Heaven and a new Earth
and the Bible says blessed are the meek
they will inherit the earth so
ultimately we build houses and we
inhabit them we have mansions in the
city we live in this world God fulfills
his original plan all right question
number two it says I know that the
sacrificial goat in Leviticus 16
represents Christ which can you explain
who the scapegoat represents yeah on the
day of atonement there were two goats
that were chosen one was called the
Lord's goat and it is sacrificed it
represents the Lord it dies for sin its
blood is applied the other goat they
used to transfer the guilt of the nation
to this goat it was carried off in the
wilderness it was banished forever and
they understand that represents the sort
of the Eternal uh separation from the
devil and sin of God's people that that
scapegoat is the one that it's not the
sin Bearer in the sense that Christ is
this is the devil paying for his own
sins he's instigated that's right and
the scapegoat was never sacrificed no no
Bloodshed and it's banished forever next
question that we have how long did Adam
and Eve live in the Garden of Eden
before they sinned
well it you just do a little speculation
and if the last command of God after
everything is perfect he says be
fruitful and multiply they are perfectly
healthy and but sin happens before they
procreate
so we're assuming that it wasn't very
long probably a matter of weeks or
months of the devil
he sent a blitzkrieg and attacked him
caught him off guard shortly after
creation all right last question uh what
is the difference between the old and
the New Covenant well that's a big
question for a short one well when you
take your Bible and you split it into
you get the New Testament or New
Covenant is talking about when Jesus
actually did come the old Covenant is
the law written on Stone the New
Covenant is a law written on our hearts
hey thank you so much friends God bless
keep us in your prayers and we
appreciate your support in the program
we are faith-based study together again
next week
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]